[Music]
hi there I'm Hannah Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here in the Ubisoft booth at e3
2014 and it's my distinct pleasure to be
here with Donald Glover and Danny Pudi
how are you guys doing today pretty
great this is my first time here
like I used to hear about it a lot so I
I really it's it's been pretty like it
intense lots of lights colors and cool
games that I I want to buy all of them
all the games all the games I mean I
don't have to they they practically give
them away here which is really also
awesome so it's been great even keeping
you guys pretty busy what have you been
up to so far we've been demoing the
games we got the demo Far Cry 4 which is
awesome we got to do the co-op version
which is great cuz Donald and I miss
each other we don't get to hang out so
we try and blow each other up on crack
as much as possible like the co-op
version on this is like perfect for us
so like we yeah it's been in a coffee
shop once we were both getting
croissants you know yeah that was the
last time was like we just happened to
be there so is your relationship similar
to the the community relationship that
troy and abed relationship at all i mean
i think we're we were were able to sort
of coexist separately i guess a little
bit better probably family if you were
like of it and you had a family and kids
like it'd be really sad dorium my wife
what actually she but my kids probably
wouldn't like it so i think we tend to
exist and have our separate lives and I
think that's what's fun about this is it
didn't take a lot of convincing to come
here and they're like hey you wanna play
some video games meet the inventor of
tetris and hang out with Donald and play
far cry 4 I was like yeah I need to do
this you mentioned your kids are your
kids into gaming yet I know they're only
like 2 or so right there two and a half
I keep trying to get them in front of
the ps4 and they're just like not into
it yet and I'm like let's get it
together kids wait be ok really
impressed with boxes we're gonna take
them to the box convention right
later they loved that the boxes of the
Xbox and ps4 they loved the boxes the
tapes
yeah ripping them open yeah the Box e3
is coming like in August right this
would be good
I heard that box technology is rapidly
evolving it's like next-gen box it's
getting so big it's getting a lot of 3d
three like 40 printing technology where
you know the Sun or like some magnets
are like will make the boxes open this
bit is getting really explained here
most of what you guys are saying over
there but I Box conventions are the rage
well let's bring it back to farcry I
know you guys were big far cry 3 fans if
I'm if I've been informed correctly what
are you excited about 4 farcry 4
himalayas is dope and like it's nice to
I mean like I really enjoy the jungle
like that's one of my favorite places
but Himalayas just kind of fly and the
fact that you can like live from out in
the mountain
I spy but like like we were saying the
coop features like really good for like
friends to like play like the game with
each other so like that and weaponizing
weaponizing elephants is pretty fun lan
izing elephants is long overdue I don't
think they've had a fair shot over the
course of elephant history and I think
you know the Himalayas is a natural spot
for for this game also for Donnell and I
to meet together because we can co-op we
can go on a gyrocopter together that's
sweet
new a season of The Bachelor you know I
mean we're going all these crazy
adventures together except that it's in
the Himalayas there's grenades and it's
a chance for us to live vicariously and
show our love in a different way more
explosions than The Bachelor probably
they're more explosions the better so
what other kinds of games do you like to
play is this your typical type of game
or what kind of gamers would you say you
are I think if we're going like back
back back in time I mean like I used to
play Mortal Kombat a ton when I was a
kid my mom works for a video game
company so we had a Mortal Kombat my
garage which was great because in high
school that's all you want to do
tetris obviously we talked about
Excitebike earlier I love that it's
crazy good time I used to be able to
like build your own track on Excitebike
which was really what else paper boy I
love trying to get that paper in that
than their mailbox go to like video
games to make fun of I mean but I love
bonk I really did love bunk but it is
the go to like remember punk like no one
play bunked except for me it was like a
baby with a big head for you people who
are under a thousand years old bubble
all bubble Bob I liked aids odd world I
actually was gonna be a video game
writer before I got on 30 rock so like I
was really into games but now I don't
get to like games with like stories they
take a lot of investment so like usually
we like one-off like we can complete a
mission on far cry 4 like easy like
Street Fighter or something where it's
just like one-off where you don't have
to like invest it in like you know a lot
of these games like require not having a
girlfriend right you're you're sunk now
I'm in deep trouble
you're done I'm just kind of waiting I
think my wife is probably like thankful
though that I have some escape they do
have a place to go to and you know and
become a man in the forest or in the
like you know the moms of homeless I
could become a man in the Himalayas
there you go I mean far cry 4 well I
could hang out with you guys all day but
unfortunately I'm getting the wrap it up
and a signal so thank you very much if
you guys liked this interview want to
have questions for Donald and Danny
tweet at an approximate hashtag GameSpot
e3 and at them as well they're cool
you
[Music]